[Music]
about 300,000 people supposedly live in
benefit officially that makes it
Germany's 18th largest city but there
are those in Germany who question its
very existence including plenty of
Berliners start a city nobody knows or
knows about it but not where that keeps
things nothing there is there nothing
yeah good
nada benefit Bielefeld what's that then
discarnate the Bielefeld conspiracy a
conspiracy in which signposts transport
listings car registration plates and so
on are all forged by the secret service
or by alien beings in order to simulate
a non-existent city it started 20 years
ago as a joke among students
but now an online search for benefit
gift assist or Bielefeld doesn't exist
we'll turn up about 12,000 entries what
definitely does exist however is a
wealth of literature on the city one
such book is by Tomas vicodin the affair
is flourishing they all survive as far
as its public image goes Peter felt
really is a city that doesn't quite
exist you wouldn't think of it as an
important city
[Music]
Tomas Lydon also wrote the script for
the film the Bielefeld conspiracy it
sees for residents fighting secret
forces to secure the existence of their
disputed city it was shot on location at
the Spartanburg Castle the medieval
building is a city landmark but wrapped
in scaffolding it does lend the
conspiracy theory a certain degree of
plausibility journalist Oliva gaya
Isabella felt native who lives in Berlin
and he's no stranger to such accusations
[Music]
it's like a blank slate a space onto
which people can project whatever they
want including the Bielefeld conspiracy
nobody knows the city so you can say
whatever you want about it and people
believe it and laugh themselves silly
long distort horrible event it's a city
that gets no respect even the university
building is often called an
extraterrestrial spaceship rather than a
place of higher learning
[Music]
so who is it that parades the streets of
Bielefeld in broad daylight are they
aliens or are they the true residents
celebrating the 800th birthday of their
city with a carnival of cultures we look
at it's multicultural there's always
something going on here forests Meadows
lakes at least one the combination of
city and countryside is perfect you can
get anywhere on the Municipal Railway by
which he means the subway even though
only seven of the more than 60 stations
are in fact underground
[Music]
Bielefeld first earned the title of city
when the surrounding villages were
absorbed into it in 1973 everyone used
to be bothered that they didn't live in
Munich or Hamburg and everyone talked
about how great it is in the big cities
they wanted to make up for that sense of
inferiority by going to really great
bars with that big-city feeling they
liked to show visitors those great neon
advertising billboards because they
reminded them a bit of Piccadilly Circus
and Piccadilly Circus the fine old
buildings at the Old Market Square are
testimony to Bielefeld earlier
incarnation as a thriving merchant
centre mayor Pitt Claussen has been
pushing to use the Bielefeld conspiracy
line for the city's birthday
celebrations exist that's a great
conversation opener then I can talk
about how great our city is explain what
goes on here if we didn't have this
opener we'd have to invent it on in
zofran when it isn't open Anna Kaber
stop Thomas TNF in
meanwhile the people of Bielefeld will
be celebrating the 800th birthday of
their city all year even if their
trademark castle isn't dressed for the
occasion
[Music]